i
[Música]
en su primera rueda de prensa como
presidente electo de irán
ebrahim raisi aseguró que la política
exterior de irán no se limitará al
acuerdo nuclear de 2015 sino que se
enfocará en mejorar los lazos con sus
vecinos del golfo pérsico dijo que el
programa de misiles balísticos de la
república islámica no es negociable y no
se mostró dispuesto a una reunión con
joe biden tenemos reportes de de tera
el presidente del gobierno español en
pedro sánchez anunció que propondrá al
consejo de ministros aprobar los
indultos para nueve de los líderes
separatistas catalanes encarcelados que
fueron condenados por su papel en el
referendo independentista de 2017 la
medida de rechazada tanto por la
oposición como por los propios
independentistas que reclaman amnistía
una abstención de más del 66 por ciento
fue la principal protagonista de las
elecciones regionales y departamentales
en francia los partidos del presidente
manuel macro ni de la líder de extrema
derecha marine lepén no obtuvieron los
resultados esperados y quedaron en mejor
posición la de la esperada las fuerzas
tradicionales de la política francesa
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí entra el 24 mi
nombre es liliana valencia iniciamos en
irá porque el presidente electo ebrahim
raisi ofreció su primera rueda de prensa
después de las elecciones país y no se
mostró dispuesto a reunirse con el
presidente de eeuu o joe biden aseguró
que la política exterior de irán se
enfocará en mejorar sus lazos con sus
vecinos del golfo pérsico y que no se
limitará al acuerdo nuclear de 2015
además sostuvo que el programa de
misiles balísticos de su país no es
negociable
previamente hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal en teherán catalina gómez
quien nos entregó detalles de esta
información varias conclusiones salen de
esta primera rueda de prensa
recién electo presidente ibrahim rice y
es un hombre concreto empezó la rueda de
prensa en el momento que era no se
extendió mucho como son unas células
presidentes de irán y sus preguntas
fueron bastante concretas tuvo dos
mensajes tanto de la política interna
como de la política externa en alto la
política interna su mensaje fue
recuperar la economía ayudar a la
población más necesitada y recuperar esa
confianza de la población en el sistema
y en el régimen que está debilitado como
quedó en evidencia en estas elecciones
de la participación fue de menos del 50
por ciento en cuanto a política exterior
habló del acuerdo nuclear dijo que su
política exterior no giraría en torno a
este acuerdo pero que si eeuu volvía a
cumplir los compromisos irán volvería a
hacerlo siempre pensando en el beneficio
de la población dijo que los misiles y
la participación de irán en la región no
eran negociable y en cuanto a esas
ejecuciones masivas en la década de los
80 de las cuales él hizo parte dijo que
defendía los derechos humanos y que
fueron los acusados
entonces quienes rompieron esos derechos
humanos cuando se oponían a las reglas
de la república islámica hablamos ahora
de españa porque el presidente del
gobierno pedro sánchez anunció que
propondrá al consejo de ministros
aprobar los indultos para nueve de los
líderes independentistas catalanes que
se encuentran en prisión por su rol en
el referendo independentista de 2017 sin
embargo los mismos independentistas
catalanes rechazaron el anuncio porque
solicitan amnistía e independencia en
vez de indulto también los partidos
opositores de derechas se mostraron en
contra de la propuesta que se espera sea
aprobada este martes justamente por el
consejo de ministros y eso es lo que el
gobierno de españa ha decidido
afrontar el problema
buscar la concordia
por eso mañana pensando en el espíritu
constitucional de concordia propondré al
consejo de ministros conceder el indulto
a los nueve condenados en el juicio del
procés que hoy están en prisión
la alta comisionada de la onu para los
derechos humanos michelle bachelet
entregó un informe que evidencia el
deterioro de los derechos humanos en el
mundo
bachelet expresó su preocupación
particular por las violaciones
justamente también de derechos humanos
en países como china etiopía y rusia
denunció el más grave retroceso en
materia de derechos humanos que jamás se
haya visto para recuperarnos de la
cascada más grave y de mayor alcance de
retrocesos en materia de derechos
humanos necesitamos una visión que
cambie la vida y una acción concertada
de seguimiento necesitamos una economía
de derechos humanos que en toda su
diversidad compartan mejores compromisos
para reducir las desigualdades y
promover todos los derechos humanos a
pesar de ser culpados por la derrota
sufrida por armenia a manos de su vecino
azerbaiyán en el más reciente conflicto
por la región de nagorno karabaj el
primer ministro ni compasión ya no
obtuvo el poder tras unas elecciones
parlamentarias que en las que buscaba
dar una salida a la crisis su partido se
llevó más del 53 por ciento de los votos
nuestra corresponsal en ereván beatriz
arslanían no se entrega a los detalles
los resultados finales de las elecciones
parlamentarias anticipadas en armenia
fueron anunciados hace tan solo unas
horas antes con la marcada victoria del
partido oficialista del primer ministro
interino nico el pajín al que no obtuvo
casi el 54% de los votos por otro lado
la coalición armenia encabezada por el
ex presidente robert kocharián se
posicionó en el segundo lugar con 21 por
ciento de los votos y ante esto denunció
las posibilidades de fraude en el
proceso electoral este final fue
realmente sorpresivo especialmente si
tenemos en cuenta los resultados
arrojados en las encuestas previas que
en muchas ocasiones anunciaban el
triunfo de la coalición armenia en estas
elecciones participó alrededor de un 49
por ciento de la población empadronada y
en un contexto de intensa polarización
social los ánimos de los ciudadanos
varían entre la alegría y el descontento
o la angustia es importante tener en
cuenta que uno de los puntos de mayor
entrenamiento a esta reelección es la
política exterior que llevaría adelante
el primer ministro niccoló página
especialmente las relaciones que tejería
con turquía con azerbaiyán como así
también con rusia por el momento hoy el
primer ministro interino a nicole para
gillian convocó a los ciudadanos a una
concentración para celebrar esta
victoria en la plaza de la república de
yereván
y hablamos ahora de francia donde la
agrupación nacional partido de extrema
derecha de marín lp el estúpido revés en
las elecciones regionales y
departamentales al igual que centrista
la república en marcha del presidente en
manuel macro en las fuerzas
tradicionales de la política francesa el
conservador partido de los republicanos
y el partido socialista obtuvieron
mejores resultados de lo esperado en la
primera ronda celebrada este domingo
queda mucho en juego para la segunda
vuelta de la semana que viene sin
embargo la principal protagonista de las
elecciones fue la abstención superior al
60%
el sorprendente éxito de los poderes
tradicionales de la política francesa
el partido conservador los republicanos
salió de nuevo a flote y la izquierda
del partido socialista se mantuvo firme
la izquierda radical la extrema derecha
sufrieron resultados decepcionantes la
agrupación nacional de marine lepén
alcanzó resultados por debajo de lo
esperado en casi todos los ámbitos en
estas elecciones regionales las
encuestas señalaban la semana pasada que
su partido podría alzarse con la
victoria en seis regiones pero sólo lo
consiguió en una y obtuvo menos del 20
por ciento del voto nacional un
retroceso que lepén achacó a la
abstención récord el domingo más de 6
personas sobre 10 no acudieron a votar
como y publiquen son como republicana
sólo puedo lamentar este desastre cívico
que ha deformado la realidad electoral
de todo el país y produjo una impresión
engañosa de la actual correlación de
fuerzas políticas entre tanto el partido
conservador los republicanos se alzó con
la victoria con más del 27 por ciento
del voto nacional su candidato en la
norteña región altos de francia xavier
bertrand tuvo un gran resultado
consiguiendo casi la victoria en esta
primera ronda
una victoria que para él es un signo de
que su partido es el baluarte más
efectivo contra la extrema derecha de
valdés ya de por si esta noche rebajamos
la fuerza del frente nacional de
demagogia sus propuestas estériles su
intolerancia todo lo que divide y que
representa el frente nacional y tú es
que luzco nacional en la izquierda el
partido socialista y los verdes ganaron
más de lo esperado
consiguiendo respectivamente cerca del
15 y el 13 por ciento del voto nacional
el partido socialista incluso podría
hacerse con el poder en cinco regiones
para él manuel macro fue una noche dura
en comparativa su partido es joven no
existía en las anteriores regionales de
2015 y se notó al nivel departamental y
regional no consiguió ni una sola región
a pesar de que 13 de los candidatos eran
ministros del gobierno de macrón sólo
alcanzaron el quinto puesto a nivel
nacional con poco más del 10 por ciento
de los votos en noticias del continente
africano 37 millones de ciudadanos están
llamados hoy a las urnas en etiopía
donde se realizan elecciones
legislativas y regionales en medio de la
crisis humanitaria que se vive en la
región
a causa de la actual el conflicto armado
el objetivo es renovar los 547 escaños
de la cámara de representantes populares
de etiopía y también los consejos
regionales en los cuales se estima se
consolida el apoyo hacia el primer
ministro había mete problemas de
seguridad han generado que un quinto de
las circunscripciones no pudieran
organizar los comicios
las urnas salieron de la comisión
electoral bajo escolta policial este
lunes los etíopes están llamados a votar
en las elecciones legislativas y
regionales unos comicios que desde hace
un año han sido aplazados varias veces
debido a la crisis sanitaria y a la
violencia que golpea la región de tigre
tenemos muchas esperanzas en estas
elecciones son muy importantes para la
estabilidad de nuestro país viene para
rezar por la paz y la unidad no hemos
tenido comida durante mucho tiempo
apenas podíamos pagar el pan hemos visto
demasiado sufrimiento causado por la
economía y los problemas de seguridad
queremos un futuro mejor
nombrado en 2018 el primer ministro de
etiopía despertó la esperanza de unidad
en un país donde conviven más de 80
comunidades étnicas sin embargo había
ahmed premio nobel de la paz en 2019
perdió su reputación con el incremento
de la violencia sectaria durante su
mandato hoy el jefe del gobierno quiere
reforzar su legitimidad en las urnas
tenemos delante nuestro la elección
entre la destrucción y el desarrollo tan
tan
quiero llamarlos a unirse a proteger su
país y hacerlo prosperar me diga a mí
en la carta chufa el galo debido a la
guerra un quinto de las
circunscripciones no pudieron organizar
la votación por lo que en ciertas
regiones fue pospuesta para el mes de
septiembre en el tigre donde los
enfrentamientos y la hambruna no cesan
no hay fecha fijada las elecciones serán
observadas de cerca por la comunidad
internacional inquieta por la exclusión
de un número tan alto de electores
en nicaragua continúan los allanamientos
y órdenes de captura contra líderes
opositores en la noche del domingo fue
arrestado el periodista miguel mora
quien se convierte en el quinto
precandidato presidencial ese detenido
por orden del gobierno de daniel ortega
esto de cara a las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo 7 de
noviembre por es acusado de supuestos
delitos contra la soberanía y con él ya
son 17 los opositores detenidos
vamos con información deportiva porque
los organizadores de los juegos
olímpicos de tokio junto con el gobierno
de japón limitaron el número de
espectadores a 10.000 para cada
escenario un día después de que los
expertos advirtieron que realizar el
evento sin fanáticos sería la mejor
opción y la menos riesgosa en el marco
de la pandemia de kobe 19 niños y
maestros el comité olímpico y el comité
paralímpico junto a japón y en línea con
las restricciones del gobierno para
eventos multitudinarios huixtán de yoga
y kan autoritarias hemos decidido
establecer el límite de espectadores en
el 50 por ciento de la capacidad de los
estadios hasta un máximo de 10.000
espectadores
finalizamos en españa donde tras 15
meses de cierre de las discotecas
reabrieron sus puertas este domingo en
la noche en cataluña gracias a la mejora
de los indicadores epidemiológicos y al
avance de la campaña de vacunación un
ejemplo de esto lo vemos a continuación
en la ciudad de barcelona
rostros felices atuendos ligeros y
música alegre la vida nocturna ha
retomado su curso en barcelona la
reapertura de las discotecas marca el
regreso de los turistas a la capital de
la fiesta
hemos estado en cuarentena durante tanto
tiempo es increíble estar aquí estamos
felices finalmente es verano para esta
discoteca es el final del túnel después
de 15 meses de cierre el establecimiento
casi que ahora ha sido muy duro para
todos como los primeros en cerrar como 0
porno y estamos siendo los últimos en
abrir entonces si una pandemia ha
afectado a tal nivel la sociedad
española' imagínense cómo afecta a los
primeros que cerramos y a los últimos
que abriremos últimamente con la
evolución de la vacunación que está
siendo muy amplio a nivel europeo
las expectativas mejores hay optimismo a
pesar de algunas restricciones vigentes
como el indicador del 50% de la
capacidad de recepción o la obligación
de llevar una mascarilla para bailar en
cataluña las discotecas también tendrán
que cerrar antes a las 3 y 30 de la
mañana sin embargo es insuficiente para
estropear la fiesta de que esto vuelva
un poquito a la normalidad de antes
aunque nos gustaría que abriesen hasta
un poquito más tarde eso sería ideal si
volviese todo hasta las 6 de la mañana 7
ya vamos un poco poco a poco a poco está
bien estas medidas se volverán a evaluar
durante las próximas dos semanas y si
todos los indicadores están en verde la
gente en barcelona finalmente podrá
bailar hasta la madrugada
con esta información llegamos al final
de esta emisión de noticias entradas 24
porque ustedes pueden continuar como de
nuestra programación quédense con
nosotros
[Música]
france24